All right, Steve Lawson, we're here in a room at the Valley Library.
It's the 14th day of November 2011.
Okay, so today we will principally be talking about the Institute at OSE, but there's a couple
of things I wanted to touch on sort of the past chronology of our talks that we didn't
actually get to.
And the first is an important question.
I think that's that you can just sort of trace how you advance into the ranks of executive
officer to make sure that you've got the officer in the role of that.
Sure, that was quite a surprise.
I think in our last conversation, I'd outlined some of the financial problems that the
Institute had been chronically experiencing and these go way back to the 1970s, where staff
was asked to take pay cuts and the contribution to the retirement plan was decreased periodically
for a set period of time.
So employees in the Institute were no strangers to financial hardship.
Salaries were not very competitive, fairly low, probably when compared salaries to roughly
equivalent positions in academia or in the private sector in that time.
But I think people had a great passion for the Linus Point Institute, which is why I worked
there, certainly, because I really felt strongly about the mission and I really liked Linus
Pauling.
The more I found out about him, the more I liked him, and I was very pleased and kind
of honored to be part of the Linus Point Institute of Science and Medicine.
And as my skills developed in science, and I started to get involved in more and more
projects, I found it very challenging and lots of fun.
And I think I demonstrated some aptitude, or I don't think I would have been asked
by Pauling and others to participate at the level I was asked.
Then in the mid-1980s, Emil Zucco-Condo, who succeeded Art Robinson as President Director
of the Institute, was getting very interested in using a relatively new technique called
two-dimensional polyacrylamide gel electrophoresis to profile proteins that might distinguish tumor
cells from primary tissue, from metastatic tumor tissue.
And we set up a laboratory together and started on a fairly productive collaboration.
And as a result of that, I became co-director of the lab for research and gene regulation,
and reported directly to Emil Zucco-Condo.
And Emil and I got along very, very well.
I really respected him, an extraordinarily intelligent person.
I can see why his collaboration with Pauling was so successful in the early 1960s.
And as the institute moved to the point of inflection of the decades, Emil's tenure was
coming to an end.
And as I mentioned last time, Emil and Rick Hicks departed from the institute because I think
Emil was unwilling to make some of the changes that the board felt were necessary to align
income with outgoing.
So the institute had expanded pretty dramatically under Emil's direction and had become kind
of a broad molecular biological biomedical research organization.
So it had some areas of orthomolecular medicine, but it also had areas that were really not
germane to orthomolecular medicine that were of interest to Emil, specifically, and to
others, of course, who were carrying out the specific research project at the institute.
So when Emil left, and Linus Pauling, of course, had become sick and was not interested in
carrying out many administrative responsibilities, Linus Pauling, Jr. stepped in to fill an
obvious void there.
And that began kind of my long association with Linus Pauling, Jr.
I got to know him very well, and I think we worked together very well as well.
I took care of the day-to-day management of the institute and Linus Pauling, Jr. as a
result of his experience and wisdom, provided some direction to me as well.
I think I mentioned last time that when the institute was going through this reorganization
a fate of different research projects and researchers within the organization was really
up in the air and people weren't sure whether they would be asked to remain with the
institute or whether they would be laid off.
So researchers whose work was pretty carefully aligned, excuse me, with the newly refocused
orthomolecular medical mission felt fairly confident about remaining with the institute
and others were really anxious, of course.
At some point there was a board meeting, and there were board meetings more often during
this period.
Board meetings had been relatively rare during my tenure at the institute.
I was never sure exactly when a board meeting was being held.
I think that they were held probably as often as required by law, but not very often.
But during this period of change in turmoil board meetings were quite regular, and of course
I was unsure about my fate within the institute as well, because the work I was doing was really
not related specifically to orthomolecular medicine, so I was concerned that I might
be losing my job.
And I was aware of a meal's imminent departure, so I obviously was concerned about my future
then too.
And it came as a great surprise during a board meeting when I was summoned to the To Linus
Planck's office where the board was meeting by Dorothy Monroe, and I had no idea why they
wanted to talk to me or what I could offer to the board, but nevertheless I went down
it, met with the board, and at that time they introduced some changes that they had
been thinking about, and they asked me for my opinion of these changes.
And on the board and the office there, somebody had written out kind of an organizational
chart for the institute.
And I looked at it and made a few comments and generally thought that I opined and I thought
it was a good opinion.
I mean it was a good idea that they had decided to really make clear the responsibilities
within the institute, because it was something that was of great concern to people, because
the institute had operated, managed early as a bit of a black box, and decisions were
not always clear, and the rationale for decisions were not always obvious.
And I think that's true in any organization, but in a small organization it can be, it can
cause a lot of problems.
So during the board meeting they asked me also, I believe, if I was interested in participating
in the reorganized institute, and without giving it much thought at the time, I said yes.
I was a bit surprised and also I think a bit flattered by this invitation to assume
more responsibility within the institute, and I thought it was likely to be quite a challenge.
At that time I had no idea just how dramatic a challenge it would be, but I knew that it
would be stimulating, and like I said earlier, I liked to solve problems, and I saw quite
a few problems, and I thought that I might be helpful in tackling them.
So your panel changed at some point, Bill, from the executive office of the chief executive
office?
Right.
It went through metamorphosis.
Initially Linus Pauling had asked me to be, I think the title was Assistant to the
President, when he assumed very temporarily the role of President, and I took that job
seriously.
I didn't really know what it entailed, but I took it seriously.
And I started thinking about things that needed to be acted upon at the institute, and I
think I produced a list of some things that needed to be done, and my rationale for
doing them, and gave that to Linus Pauling, and he left for a few months to go down to
Big Sur.
So there was really a bit of a vacuum, and I think Linus Pauling Jr. recognized that
his father at that time, recognized that his father really had no interest in managing
the institute, and I was left without much direction at that point.
I'd been given a new title, but I didn't really have a firm grasp of what I was expected
to do, and I didn't really feel that I had the authority to do what I thought was in
the best interest in the institute, because I was not the chief administrator of the institute.
So my job title changed when the board reorganized the institute and asked me to become
involved in management from that to executive officer.
And I think executive officer has come an old terminology from the military, and maybe
after a year or so as executive officer, I was named chief executive officer.
Was there any significant difference in the power you had, or your response to the
goal, is there a title change?
I think it was just a title change.
I think it was just recognizing the actual duties that I was performing at the institute.
Because Linus Pauling Jr. of course was still living in Hawaii, and he would come to
the institute periodically, sometimes as often as once a month for a day or two, excuse
me, but I was handling all the day-to-day administrative tasks at the institute, and also we had
litigation at that time and trying to, we were trying to chart a course for the future,
and all those things I was acting on on a daily basis and thinking about and discussing
with my colleagues at the institute and elsewhere.
I believe he became chairman of the board of trustees, and Linus Pauling Sr. at some
point became director of research, which was a little odd because technically Linus Pauling
on the board, the board was responsible.
I reported to the board, so I reported to Linus Pauling, but as director of research he
also technically reported to me as chief executive officer, so it was kind of an odd situation
but it didn't interfere with our relationship or any of our activities because I don't think
we let titles get in the way.
Another thing that we touched on in our last meeting that I wanted to follow up on the real
question here was the Linus Pauling Foundation, so I mentioned that in the context of something
that the TS rat was involved, and I wondered what became of that.
Right.
As I mentioned, some of the TS rat's activities were unknown to employees of the institute.
We became vaguely aware at some point that other organizations, with kind of a parallel
mission to the institute, were being set up by Pauling and Raff, and that caused a little
consternation because we weren't sure if, and I wasn't in management at that time, but
we, the employees at the institute weren't sure if these other organizations were going
to be competitive with the institute, were they going to compete for funds for the same
donors, for instance, or the same organizations?
And at some point, it became clear to me that it really wasn't strictly competitive but
I didn't really see the rationale for having independent organizations to carry out this
work.
So I believe that Raff and Pauling set up the Linus Pauling Heart Foundation because they
were anxious to sort of get around the management of the institute and raise money and carry
out clinical trials in vitamin C and heart disease, specifically atherosclerosis, and do
more investigative work, maybe mechanistic work on lysine, proline, vitamin C and lipoprotein
A, which was the main focus of Pauling's research interests at that time in North and
Milwaukee, the medicine.
But Raff had, as he and Pauling were starting to grow apart because Pauling, I think, was
expressing some decrease in confidence in Raff's behavior and abilities.
Pauling decided to wrap up the Linus Pauling Heart Foundation and I believe this was probably
after Raff had left the institute but here was this organization that had an independent
life, had headquarters in a small office building in California, and just a few blocks from
the institute and Raff had apparently hired several people to do work there.
So they were on the payroll and some of the activities of the foundation apparently
were surprised Pauling because when he was informed about these things he was not pleased
about some of the activities the foundation was under taken.
So he asked me if I would wind up the Linus Pauling Heart Foundation and transfer the assets
to the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine to carry out work and heart disease.
So I told him I'd be happy to do that and set about legally dissolving the Linus Pauling
Heart Foundation and taking the physical assets back to the 440 page mill road facility
and also transferring the financial assets to a restricted account at the Linus Pauling
Institute of Science and Medicine.
Okay, so the last, at the end of our interview last time we were at the point where Pauling
Shide, which is 1994, he received a couple of pieces of substantial gifts that had kept
the institute more or less alive but you also know you need to leave it off because of
the return to it.
And in 1996 the institute moved to OSU so I'm interested in knowing how that process
carried out.
Let me back up briefly in 1994, it was a very pivotal year in many respects not just
because of Pauling's death but it was also the year that we celebrated the 20th anniversary
of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine.
And we started early, let's see, I think it must have been late spring or early summer.
Maybe it was late spring.
Let me see now, I'm confused about the year, was it 1993 or 1994?
Also it was 1993 when we celebrated the 20th anniversary, that would have been the
appropriate year at Rangstorf House in Mountain View, California.
And that was an opportunity for Pauling to see some of his old friends and colleagues.
We invited quite a few of his colleagues from academic institutions and local donors and
friends of the institute.
And of course the staff, faculty and staff of the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine
and their guests.
It was a really terrific event at a beautiful renovated Victorian house that was on the
mud flats in Mountain View and special collections came representatives of special collections
here at OSU.
Came down with some of Pauling's medals and awards that he'd already given to the university.
So they were on display and we had posters, scientific posters and it was really a great time
for Pauling to meet and greet perhaps for the last time some of his associates.
And then in 1994, also to celebrate the 20th anniversary of the Linus Pauling Institute
of Science and Medicine, we decided to convene a large scientific conference.
In the institute had historically convened a number of conferences.
One was to honor Bjorn Nordinstrom from the Carolinsky Institute.
Pauling became quite interested in his bioelectric theory of cancer therapy, which is quite interesting.
So there was a symposium to honor him and then some years earlier there had been another
symposium called Nutrition Health and Peace convened by the institute with presentations
by a whole raft of people doing work in orthomolecular medicine, molecular biology and chemistry.
Again, a little bit to honor Linus Pauling's work in orthomolecular medicine science and
peace.
And of course there had been birthday parties for Linus Pauling and the Linus Pauling and
the work for humanitarianism.
So there had been a lot of events throughout the history of the Linus Pauling Institute,
some were the fundraising focus and some of the scientific focus.
But of course, Linus Pauling was always at the midst of these occasions.
So we decided that an appropriate 20th anniversary event would be a conference, a scientific conference,
organized around the theme of orthomolecular medicine.
Linus Pauling was pleased to hear about this and we decided to call it the therapeutic
potential of biological antioxidants.
And we had a scientific committee and organizing committee set up at the institute that reviewed
poster abstracts and invited people to speak at the conference.
I remember going into Pauling's office to ask him what he thought of our provisional title
of the therapeutic potential of biological antioxidants and in his very characteristic
way, he leaned back in his chair and closed his eyes and thought for a minute and without
even opening his eyes, he said to me, well, I think it's fine but we shouldn't forget that
molecules like vitamin C serve many functions in the body.
They're not strictly committed to being only antioxidants.
They also have very other important properties and we shouldn't forget that and I agreed
with them completely but he gave his blessing to our provisional title for the conference.
So he also agreed to be the keynote speaker at the conference and this was scheduled for
the fall of 1994, September and people like Bruce Ames and Balthes Frye, Maret Traiber,
Lester Packer, Enrique Cadenas, a lot of people in the free radical field were there.
And I hadn't met some of these people before, I'd met Bruce Ames and Balthes Frye as early
as 1989 when they came to the institute to give a seminar on vitamin C because Ames
had published with Frye a paper in PNAS that year showing that a score bay is the outstanding
antioxidant in human blood and a pecking order at number one and Pauline of course was
very excited by that paper and they were invited to come and give seminars during the
day of the earthquake actually as it turned out.
So there were a lot of interesting people invited to speak at our conference and then of
course Pauline died at the end of August.
So I asked Henry Taube who was one of Pauline's friends and had done work in free radical
chemistry as well.
If he would step in as a substitute for Pauline and give the keynote address at our conference
and he was happy to do so, that was very gracious of him to consent to do that at the last
minute because he was very active at Stanford and I'm sure there were many demands on his
time and I thought it was terrific that he really rose to the occasion and agreed to give
that talk which went very well.
I drove him up to Tiburon, picked him up at Stanford and drove him to Tiburon that day
to give the talk and he did a outstanding job really, really thrilled to group there.
So after Pauline had died of course and before his death we were engaged in analyzing options
for the future of the institute and I discussed some ideas with some of the people that had
attended the therapeutic potential biological antioxidants in September and then was
approached in 1994, 1993, 1994, I was also working with a fellow named Bill Kemp who
was introducing me to people in different universities around the country and we had
been talking as I mentioned last time with people all over the place.
Bill had arranged for me to meet the governor of Oklahoma at the Jonathan Club in Los Angeles
because the governor of Oklahoma was on a trip as many governors do to try to get businesses
to relocate or move some of their operations to the state of Oklahoma because that's the
economic engine that drives the state.
So I met with the governor at the Jonathan Club, it was kind of a funny meeting that
was in a really luxurious room at the Jonathan Club and the governor was there with his chief
of staff and maybe a dozen or 14 other people, they were all paying wrapped attention to everything
that he said and did and they were all aligned on one side of a long, long conference table
and it was me on the other side of the conference table.
I had no people, I had no retinue, I had no advisers, just me and I had a great conversation
with him and he invited me and Linus Pond Jr to go to Oklahoma City to make a presentation
to the president of the university, the president of the foundation there which operates in
a similar way to the Oregon State University Foundation here with their relationship to the
local university, or the state school I should say, but anyway getting back to more
specifically your question, other people came and made presentations to our board about
their ideas for relocation and one of the people who came was John Byrne who brought
with him, I believe he brought with him Dick Scanlan who was dean of research at that
time and Oregon State University in many ways, I mean just superficially seemed to be
a good fit because Linus Pond was his alma mater, he had already agreed to give his and his
wife's personal and professional memorabilia to Oregon State University to be housed in
a new special collections, forms are the nucleus of special collections, so it seemed like
a good fit but we weren't really sure about the specifically how the institute would work
into the program here and so John Byrne and Dick Scanlan talked about the centers and
institutes there were already extant at Oregon State University and how they were organized
and how they reported to and how they were staffed and so forth and they talked a bit about
the nutrition department and the work that was going on there, exercise and sports physiology
here in medicine, pharmacy, biochemistry and bio physics, environmental and molecular
toxicology, strong programs that seem to have some relevance to the institute's mission.
And that led to of course many discussions and meetings between staff at Oregon State
University and our staff at the Linus Pond Institute of Science and Medicine including hosting
a meeting between a committee that John Byrne had put together to seriously analyze
this prospect of the institute relocating to Oregon State University to find out whether
it was really a good thing to do or not, Joanne Leon, George Bailey, a number of other
people were on that committee and they came down to Palo Alto and I hosted them for
day and talked about the mission of the institute and how we had been funded historically, talked
a lot about the scientific work, a lot about the fundraising work.
They weren't really familiar with the term orthomolecular so we spent quite a lot of time thinking
about that and discussing it and I think they came to realize that some of the work that
Dave themselves were doing could be considered orthomolecular but they hadn't really applied
that term to their own work.
And I think as a result of those many meetings it became clear that there was a good fit between
the Linus Pond Institute and Oregon State University although it wasn't tenable to bring
the whole institute with all its employees up to Corvallis because there was just too
many people.
We had I can't remember what the specific number of employees was at that time but back
before the reorganization there were maybe 70, 75 people at the institute and then after
the reorganization that was dropped down to maybe 50 or so.
And of course with the institute moving to Oregon State University a lot of the administrator
functions that we had to assume ourselves in Palo Alto, we would no longer have to assume
so we had no need for a controller or bookkeeper or we still had need for a fundraiser but
of course the fundraising activities were going to be taken over by the OSU Foundation
so we didn't really need to have a fundraising staff to come with us to Oregon State University.
So we had broad and deep discussions about all those issues and the researchers at the
Linus Pond Institute of Science and Medicine who the dean of research and the ad hoc committee
formed by John Bern believed had the best chance of succeeding here at Oregon State
University.
We're asked to come up and meet the faculty and staff that they might interact with here
on campus in the different departments and so there were a number of visits back and
forth between OSU and LPISM.
And as a result of that Dick Scanlon was pretty frank with me about who might really succeed
at Oregon State University and what might be the most important part of the Linus Pond
Institute to bring up to Oregon State University and that led to the decision to bring a relatively
small nucleus of people about half a dozen to Oregon State University.
Now there were some people that I think could have made the transition had they wanted to
but they had for instance there was one fellow doing work that was supported by a department
of energy grant at the Institute in Palo Alto and his wife was a physician and they had
a comfortable life in the Bay Area and they really didn't want to leave and there were
other people who also were approaching retirement age and decided that it might just be best
to retire rather than move to Oregon.
So there were a lot of factors that came into play in determining who actually moved to
Corvallis but at the time we had a very, and I mentioned this the last time, a really
good contractual relationship with Unilever and Elizabeth Arden, it was continuing so the
people involved with that particular project were given offered jobs at Oregon State University
and a number of other people were as well.
I think they were about half a dozen, six or seven people total.
It was Karna McEvally who was an Irish biochemist working on the Arden supported project Vadim
Ivanov who was working in cardiovascular disease research and his wife Stetlana Ivanova.
She was a heat roomie who was doing some really good work in cytotoxic, trying to determine
the cytotoxic moiety of the vitamin C molecule and some of its derivatives myself, and it
could have been it, I'm the only one left, that's right, Connor McEvally left after the
contract supported work expired and that contract had a finite start and stop time.
Then Vadim Ivanov and his wife Stetlana decided to return to the Bay Area because they felt
more comfortable in the Bay Area, they really liked California quite a lot.
Vadim and Stetlana had come from the Moscow Cardiological Institute in Russia and found
California just paradise compared to what they left in Russia, and I think they just
had a terrific fondness for California, so they were unwilling to become permanent residents
here in Oregon, and what heat roomie left after some time.
We had an interim director at the Institute, Don Reed who I believe at that time was director
of the Environmental Health Science Center as well, and a member of the Biochemistry and
Biophysics faculty.
Yeah, so he was providing some leadership, one of the first things that we did together
was to hire an office manager, we hired Barbara McVicar, I believe she was the first employee.
Actually the first employee was Obertais who was selected by the Oregon State University
Foundation to become our fundraiser, so I worked quite closely with Oberta in the
very early days in a prize in him of some of our fundraising history, telling him a little
bit about some of the contractual relationships we had that generated income from the Institute
and also some of the charitable foundations and philanthropies who have been very kind
to the Institute over the years and talked to him about some of our big donors and be
quests and so forth.
I worked pretty closely.
Oberta had been coming down to Palo Alto to go through some of our fundraising files as
well to help him identify what was important to bring up to Oregon State.
And of course, one of the most precious resources that was transferred was our donor database
because Oregon State University, I think, recognized that absent large government grants,
it was going to be tough to keep the Institute going without reliance on the contract we
had with Arden and Unilever and also sustained giving by our donors.
So that was very important to keep that safe and to cultivate the donors and that began
even before we moved here.
So what sort of commitment did OSU make to the Institute and I guess by a person?
Well, the commitment was really spelled out in a document that we wrote jointly called
a Memorandum of Understanding which was signed in 1995 by Linus Pond Jr. myself, Paul
Risser who was the incoming president of Oregon State University.
It really spelled out how in the Institute's assets, including financial assets, fundraising
assets, physical assets, and personnel would be transferred here to the campus of Oregon
State University and the Oregon State University Foundation and how the Institute would go through
legal dissolution and also the expectations for what the University would provide from
the Institute in the future including, I think, a really key phrase about launching a capital
campaign to secure a building from the Institute as soon as that was feasible.
So right from the get go there was always the promise of a building for the Institute
because on any university campus spaces that are premium and I'm not sure who had been
in the departments.
I think Bob chemistry and bio physics may have been in the initial space that the Institute
occupied in Wendell-Gerahal but in 1995 after the Memorandum of Understanding had been executed
and renovation of this space on the fifth floor in Wendell-Gerahal was undertaken.
I would come up periodically to work hard with Dick Scanlon and others on the details and
logistics of the move from Palo Alto to Corvallis including an analysis of the laboratory
requirements.
So these laboratories were renovated, they were painted, the wood was spiffed up and polished
and sanded and new countertops were installed, air conditioning was installed because these
old leaps in the middle of the building didn't have air conditioning, building wide air
conditioning.
And there was an area that was the south part of the fifth floor of Wendell-Gerah which
was renovated for LPI.
There were still offices and laboratories there for other departments, oceanography
and atmospheric sciences to name one and some other people were still scattered throughout
that space.
It wasn't a contiguous LPI space from the west end around to the east end but it was
certainly satisfactory for the Institute's initial efforts here at Oregon State.
So the furniture, the laboratory equipment, centrifuges, laboratory supplies, chemicals,
paper, journals, a lot of the material from Pauling's office in Palo Alto, was all transferred
up, moved up in August of, excuse me, July of 1996.
And that was a very, very difficult process because we had, we managed to move ourselves,
we had professional movers of course, we hired to make this move but we had to make lots
of decisions in Palo Alto but what should be moved and what shouldn't be moved and what
could be recycled and what could be thrown away and so on and so forth.
So we filled up two dumpsters a week for well over a month with just junk that we had
no use for in the future and then of course everything was packed securely and brought up
here at Oregon State University and a lot of the journals and laboratory equipment that
wasn't in use immediately was stored in the sixth floor of Wannager and with some storage
on the fifth floor as well.
And then over time, especially after Boltz-Fry was recruited as the director of the Linus
Buying Institute here at Oregon State and following that because I think I mentioned
once before that when the candidates for director that in dad position came to interview on campus
I think they all asked the university administration the same question which is what are you going
to do to provide for growth for the institute, how will the institute grow.
And I think the university to its credit responded satisfactorily to those questions by offering
to set up a couple of faculty lines and startup packages in order to recruit new faculty.
So that was also something that I think it was an incentive in recruiting a good director
that we would have the ability to grow the institute built into the initial program.
So as Wann Boltz-Fry assumed that position and we said about recruiting new faculty,
the material that had been stored in the fifth floor had to be moved and at that time
a lot of the filing cabinets that stored Polling's files and manuscripts and so forth were
moved over here to special collections and a lot of the other stuff that we perceive
no need to keep old journals for instance that the library couldn't use and we really had
no need for or storage capacity physically and when it or were recycled.
So the university did mention some ongoing funding then it wasn't just an issue providing space
and saying that we'll have a foundation represents that I hope you raise money for all of through all
and give you some ongoing funding as well.
Well in the Memorandum of Understanding that ongoing funding to provide startup packages
and salary lines for additional faculty that was not part of the Memorandum of Understanding.
That was something that developed as a result of feedback from interviews for the director
among the director candidates and to be honest with you because I had not had professional
experience within a university environment nor had line as Polling Junior nor had the other
members of our Board of Trustees with the exception of a couple it wasn't something that we
anticipated so had we anticipated that we really needed to secure a mechanism at that time to
grow the institute we probably would have incorporated that in the Memorandum of Understanding but I
think that was an issue that escaped the analysis at that time it was only later that that was really
addressed but the idea for a building from the institute was there right from the beginning
because we recognized that the renovated part of Wintergar was not going to be sufficient.
Should the institute be successful that wasn't going to be big enough to hold the institute and
we thought that having our own building would be really a fitting tribute to Linus Polling
and I think John Byrne and people at Oregon State University agreed that that was important.
It sounds like President Byrne was crucial to this process having in the first place within
the Paul Risser around and working with his perspective as role was.
Well Paul Risser didn't have much to do with it mechanistically because he signed the
Memorandum of Understanding because by the time that document was generated John Byrne was
was leaving his president so Paul Risser was the incoming president and I think there were a lot
of press releases that about that time as well so Paul Risser had to respond as the new face of
Oregon State University about this move of the Linus Polling Institute and so forth but his
scientific training I believe was as a botanist so he probably had less appreciation for Pauling
scientific work than maybe people in the other biological sciences or in the physical sciences
like physics and chemistry he certainly was aware of Linus Polling but I think this was basically
John Byrne's baby and Dick Scanlon at that time assumed a really pivotal role, a very important
role in helping the institute to integrate into Oregon State University so Paul Risser was
certainly aware of everything and very supportive of everything but did not play a really pivotal
role early on it was really Dick Scanlon who was working very hard in this area.
What were your initial impressions with the university and for Dallas?
Well I'll be frank my initial impressions were not great I had spent my life in the East Coast
near Boston and at Stanford near San Francisco which was a hive of activity intellectual cultural
activity academic activity Silicon Valley here burgeoned during my time there so it was a very
dynamic and kind of thrilling and overstimulating type of environment that I'd grown to love.
So coming up here to Corvallis Corvallis struck me as a very sleepy tab in those days didn't seem to
have a big bookstore in town didn't seem to have many movie theaters didn't seem to have a lot of
good restaurants and to be honest it surprised me because here's a college town with tens of
thousands of students and a lot of faculty who are very bright and energetic and I was surprised
that that kind of energy and intellectual dynamism which I'm sure existed here on campus didn't
translate into more that I could perceive in town so nevertheless I felt that this was the best
option for the institute and I felt compelled from a professional standpoint to work very hard
to ensure that the institute was a success because like Linus Paul in junior we didn't really want
to see this fail and see what could become a really successful working tribute to Linus Paul
and turn into a disaster so I felt personally and professionally committed to making this work and
I realized that it was probably imperative for me to become part of this process in moving from
California to Oregon at least initially to get the institute up and running and make sure that
everything was was happening appropriately and that we didn't really lose sight of the reason
that the institute existed in the first place namely the study of orthomolecular medicine.
I was a little surprised at kind of the parochial and kind of provincial
attitude of some of the faculty here at Oregon State nutrition and so forth seemed to be a
little old-fashioned to me but I thought there was I thought the institute would probably settle
in and do quite well and there were a number of faculty who were extraordinarily bright and excited
about the institute being here and they were the ones that we were going to be working with so I
felt that I felt very good about that but I was concerned really about my my own personal
satisfaction here in Corvallis. I mean I know that the ocean is an hour and a half away and
the mountains are an hour and a half away and Portland is an hour away and but everything's at
least an hour away and in Palo Alto I was very right in the midst of things San Francisco is a short
train ride half-hour by car at that so I was concerned about that but Corvallis has changed quite
a lot over the years as well I think George Bailey was very important as well he was in environmental
and molecular tax college and director of the Marine Freshwater Biomedical Sciences Center at the
time using trout as a model to study Carson and Genesis and he'd been part of this committee that
had been set up by Dick Skinner and John Burns to sort of investigate the association at the
institute with OSU also Chris Matthews who is the chairman of the department about chemistry and
about physics I think played a very important role and part of the reason these people are
important was that new faculty coming into the institute which was essential we're going to
have their academic homes in different departments across campus and maybe even in different colleges
across campus so it's very important for the institute to be well integrated and be close to
these departmental chairs and deans as well. Joanne Leong played a very important role early on
and Tim White I think was involved as well. I can't remember all the people who constituted
search committee for the director but a number of those people were also on the search committee
and we took that job extremely seriously and reviewed numerous applications and whittled the
field down to a number of really outstanding candidates and then set about presenting each member
of the search committee presented two candidates and the choice was overwhelming for Balsray which
was terrific. Also Phil Wanger who was I believe an environmental molecular tax college who
worked on Selenium at that time was also someone who was closely associated with institute.
The higher Balsray extracts the original watershed moment. It really was a hiring Balsray
who was working of course on vitamin C was very strategic he's a terrific scientist he had
terrific recommendations from Bruce Ames the National Academy of Science member and winner of the
award. What is the award that Paul and got from Gerald Ford? National Mental Science winner as well.
So Bruce Ames recommended him extremely strongly and Balsad had we knew him as well or at least
I had known him for a few years since his parents to give a seminar at the institute back in
California and he had after leaving Bruce Ames lab as a postdoc at Berkeley he'd gone to Harvard
had a position there and was currently at Boston University School of Medicine to work on vitamin C
and atherosclerosis. So we felt that it would be terrific for the institute to get him because we
would ensure central importance of worth of molecular medicine and coincidentally one of Paul's
favorite molecules vitamin C would have a very prominent place in the institute's research and
Balsray would be a really terrific director and then with the faculty lines and startup packages
created by OSU the research office I think that really was an exciting time and that really showed
that you know we now had a mechanism for moving forward we weren't going to be we weren't going to
have to be completely dependent on fundraising from our donors in order to make the institute a
success. Now we're going to be able to be able to bring in high caliber faculty because of these
faculty lines and when those people were recruited things really started to of course progress pretty
dramatically. So a year later you hired Tori Hagan, Merrick Trayvert and Rod Dash. That's right. So the
backbone research back on the green institute all three are endowed with now. That's right. That's
right. That was very those were all very good decisions. Tori now is director of our healthy
aging program. Rod Dashwood is director of the cancer chemo protection program. Rod had been here
previously to work with George Bailey many many years ago and is one of the leading researchers in
phytochemicals and cancer in the world so that was a very important part of our research program
and Merrick Trayvert coming up from UC Berkeley from Lester Packers Lab. One of the world's authorities
on vitamin E so we thought that the combination of Tori Hagan working on agi-central micronutrients,
Rod working in phytochemical protection against carcinogenesis and Merrett working in
molecular mechanisms of vitamin E another very important physiologically antioxidant and
bolts fry working on vitamin C would really constitute a great attack in some of these problems
that had interest in my spine. I think it's probably safe to say that. I think bolts
impressed all of them. Of course Merrett Trayvert new bolts already from their prior association
at UC Berkeley but I think I think his acumen and abilities and energy and reputation as a scientist
were really critical in attracting these other candidates who were hired.
That's right. That's right. It's always been a consideration a major consideration for
becoming a principal investigator in the institute and being selected from the enormously
large pool of qualified candidates the ability to support a research program through NIH or NCI
funding or independent funding is can't be understated and it's absolutely critical to be
considered for a position like that and to achieve success in that kind of funding on a regular basis.
I think it speaks very well with a caliber of any candidate who's selected for that position.
David Williams was hired shortly. David Williams was doing very good work here in environmental
and molecular toxicology and also had assumed directorship of the Marine Freshwater Biomedical
Sciences Center so he also was very interested in phytochemical protection against Carson
and Genesis which fit right into the institute's mission and he's been a principal investigator
all this time as well. He was not recruited extremely. He was at OSU. George Bailey of course
continued to remain as a professor at OSU just retired a few years ago and I think we've been very
fortunate that none of the faculty we've recruited has left for a better job than he plays out so
I think it shows that the institute has become a collegial and productive home for people where
they feel good about their ability to carry out their research programs and like their colleagues.
At some point the institute changed its name from the Linus Polynesian to the Science Medicine
to just the Linus Polynesian to the reason why. Yeah well that's kind of the two organizations
overlapped so the institute as a 501c3 incorporated in the state of California was known from 1973
or 4 on as the Linus Polynesian Institute of Science and Medicine. The institute as it exists
here at Oregon State University has always been known as the Linus Polynesian Institute and is
was independent from the Linus Polynesian Institute of Science and Medicine. When the institute moved
here we transferred our as I said our financial assets physical assets and some personnel
to establish the Linus Polynesian Institute at Oregon State University but the Shell Organization
continued to be viable in the state of California for actually quite a few years after that
and there were a number of reasons for that. One reason was we wanted to continue to be the recipient
of be quests that named specifically the Linus Polynesian Institute of Science and Medicine
and there were a couple of be quests in the offing in which the executors and attorneys handling
the estate weren't sure that they could recognize Oregon State University of the Oregon State
University Foundation as the successor to the Linus Polynesian Institute of Science and Medicine.
So we thought rather than imperil any of these large be quests and there were several that
were quite large that it would just be best to continue that Shell Organization that could be
the recipient of some of these funds and be quests. There were also legal issues that needed to be
tied up. There was litigation with Rex E. Gerowalla about wrongful termination that needed to be
resolved. There was litigation continuing and litigation with the TSRAF that needed to be resolved
and there were, see, mainly financial and legal issues that were still dangling.
I didn't know that about Gerowalla.
Yeah, everybody in California as I might have mentioned was at will that was employment status
and it's very popular employment status in the state of California where you don't offer people
contracts. It would have been nice to offer people long-term contracts but it really was not
economically feasible to do that. We're prudent because the institute had no reliably safe source
of chronic funding. We didn't have an endowment and as you know as you're well aware the
income was up and down over the years. So in California there's what's known as at will employment
which means that you can be fired virtually anytime for no cause or you could leave at any time
with no notice. But it mainly benefits the employer, not the employee. And I feel terrible about
continuing that policy but it really there was really no way to move to any other kind of policy
at that time in Palo Alto. And of course the Linus Planning Institute of Science and Medicine really
had no absolute influence on which employees from that organization would be offered jobs
by Oregon State University. So the Linus Planning Institute of Science and Medicine was not making
job offers to its own employees to come to Corvallis to take a position. Oregon State University
was making those offers. So when it became clear which staff members in Palo Alto would be offered
jobs and which weren't offered jobs, then the people who were not going to be offered jobs.
Some retired, some had made a decision, some resigned made a decision that they didn't want to go
to Oregon anyway. And some were laid off. And Rex C. Jerawalla in turn sued the institute for
wrongful termination. And that was another one of these outstanding, excuse me, litigations that was
a reason why the institute could not go out of business right away. So there was a period of
overlap. There was the Linus Planning Institute here at Oregon State University and there was a
continuing shell organization in California, the Linus Planning Institute of Science and Medicine.
Another reason was that we had entered into a contract with Arden and Unilever and that contract
with the Linus Planning Institute of Science and Medicine. So there were lots of complicated legal
and financial issues that all of us agreed seem to be resolved by just keeping the institute,
a shell organization until all these loose ends could be tied up. And then that finally was achieved
about 2005. 2003-2005, I can't remember the exact year but that's finally when the institute
went through legal dissolution and transferred remaining assets to Oregon State University Foundation.
So I served kind of two roles. I served continuing to serve as the chief executive officer
of LPSM and then also the administrative officer for LPI here at Oregon State University.
In 2000, one of your more interesting and successful sort of public outreach efforts to
micro-metry of information center came online. I wanted to talk about that a little bit.
One thing that's interesting and looking at it is that by that point, the institute is definitely
back the way from the negative claims about Lyons State. It's getting 40 kilograms as far
as Dr. Moore calling us. He's talking about and who is active. I'm wondering if you got
left sort of the conversation behind that. Sure. Well, there's never been a litmus test for
employment at the Linus Planning Institute even in California. And people have different
behavior as far as supplementation goes. There were people in California at the institute who took
large doses of vitamin C and vitamin E and multivitamins. There were people who didn't take supplemental
vitamins. So it's never been a litmus test and nobody has ever been forced to tow the party line
about vitamin supplements. Everybody's free to make up their own mind about what to do and what
to recommend and so forth. I think the scientists associated with the Linus Planning Institute that
came on board here in Oregon all had without fail, tremendous respect for Linus Polling.
But probably as good scientists were a little skeptical of the enormous mega doses that
Polling advocated and therefore weren't comfortable in recommending these kinds of doses
themselves because they either hadn't done the research to convince them that the magnitude of
these doses was warranted in each and every case or you know that's my guess is they just weren't
familiar with a lot of Polling's arguments about this. So the Micronutrient Information Center
came about in the year 2000. I think partly as a result of conversations at early retreats
and also feedback from the scientific advisory board about the institute being a resource for
peer-reviewed scientifically accurate and updated information on the role of micronutrients
including vitamins and minerals and phytochemicals and dietary constituents in preventing disease,
treating disease when applicable and also in attaining optimum health. We had an idea somewhat
similar to this on a more limited scale back in California where we had talked about becoming a
resource for a worldwide resource for vitamin C information specifically because we had some
expertise in vitamin C obviously through Linus Polling and other staff members and we had talked
about that if there was some way to to become a resource for that kind of information and again
this was before the the internet had really taken off so it would have required hiring people with
more knowledge about nutrition and molecular biology and the intersection between nutrition and
molecular biology and medicine and we just didn't have the funds to do that at that time and it
was also probably not prudent because there was a lot of uncertainty about the future of the
institute so it would have been foolhardy to set up a new program only to lose it with the move
of the institute to a new location or the liquidation of the institute or something like that so we
never acted on that dream at that time but then this kind of resurfaced in a broader sense
before the year 2000 and the idea then of course the internet had really taken off to make
this an electronic electronically accessible database and we started thinking about who would be
appropriate to set up and manage such a database and we felt somebody with a PhD in nutrition
or in molecular biology related to nutrition and somebody with some computer skills would be
required to do this so at that time Jane Higden had just gotten a PhD in nutrition from
Oregon State University and was not interested in pursuing a career in experimental science
wasn't really interested in securing a tenure track position in academia but was interested in
staying in the scientific realm so she applied for that position and she was perfectly suited for it
she had had experience as a nurse in New York City I think she got a nursing degree from
PACE University and had gotten an undergraduate degree in biology from Stanford so she was
quite smart and had great experience and was willing to take on this task of setting up our
Migrant Community Information Center and we also hired somebody to work with her who could do the
initial computer work and software that was required to get this up and running
excuse me so the two of them collaborated on this and over the years it's developed into quite
an astonishing resource and to the extent that
when we thought about updating Pauling's book Had a Live Longer and Feel Better and this is
something that Paulie himself had pursued back in the 80s and he'd signed a contract with Brian
Lieberwitz as a matter of fact to work on an update of how to live longer feel better but
I think they had a disagreement about the strategy there in the scope of the work and that
really came to not but Linus Point Jr. and I were very interested in getting a new addition
of how to live longer and feel better published and we talked to a number of people that we thought
would be good candidates including Gladys Block we wanted somebody who was sympathetic to Pauling's
ideas and orthomolecular medicine but also extremely knowledgeable and kept up with the literature
and so forth to find someone to do that who already has a productive research career is really
difficult and we weren't able to locate anyone to carry out that work and then with the advent of
our Migrant Community Information Center it occurred to me that that was really an electronic update
of Pauling's book because now we were continuing to stay abreast of all the research information
in orthomolecular medicine and instead of compiling it into a book it was online so we decided
when the prospect of publishing an anniversary edition of How to Live Long and Feel Better came up
and I approached Oregon State University Press about that
we decided to keep the book intact add back some illustrations and other work that had been
deleted because when the book went from trade paper back sides on nice paper to
mass market paper back sides on coarse paper some of the resolution of the type was lost and
some of the illustrations just weren't appropriate so they were deleted from that mass market paper
we wanted to bring those back and decided that the best way of doing this new edition of the book
which would be the 20th anniversary edition would be to have a new forward written and afterward
kind of put the work in context with on the basis of new research that had been done since the book
was first published in 1986 and also makes some judicious annotations where people at Pauling
refers to for instance in the present tense who have died maybe indicate that the people have died
or if the RDAs changed maybe indicate why the RDAs changed or the UL and things like that so
we really limited to tinkering with the text to annotations and then providing some more text at
the beginning and end of the book and then directing people in the afterward to visit the
Micronutrient Information Center because that really provides an update of how to live longer and
feel better and over the years as the number of chapters grew in that Micronutrient Information Center
and it became and was always widely accessible through search engines it's becoming enormously
popular so recently it's been getting on on the order of 20 to 25 million hits per year
and most of those of course are not local they're all over the country all over the world
and it's been a terrific resource for people to use in consulting with their physicians about
health problems or to find out more about the biochemical or physiological action of some of these
important Micronutrients the emphasis in the Micronutrient Information Center has always been on
human health so we will revert to discussing cell culture or animal studies when there
doesn't seem to be much human data available but the focus is really on humans because humans are
the ones that are reading this they're the ones that are interested in applying this information to
their own health and that's been the focus and the information that has been written by Jane Higdon
and she was succeeded by Dr. Victoria Drake and now we have another person working with Victoria
Drake on the Micronutrient Information Center on Johnna Angelo all the articles that they
write are sent out to leading experts in the field for peer review and then they're periodically
updated as well to take into account new information new studies that might cause the institute to
modify its recommendations so the end of each of these chapters ends with a line is applying
recommendation and in many cases it's very similar to or the same as the DRIs that the food
nutrition board publishes in some cases it's different and in the case of vitamin C for instance
it's different we don't recommend the enormous quantities that line is applying recommended
in part because pharmacokinetic studies and molecular studies have revealed that the amount of
vitamin C absorbed from the gut into the bloodstream is limited by the sodium vitamin C transporters
which are relatively newly discovered they hadn't been discovered by the time Pauline died
but they are known now and it explains why only a fraction of a very small dose of vitamin C gets
from the gut into the bloodstream it's limited it's controlled by these vitamin C transporters so
it just doesn't diffuse you know against a gradient or something it really is limited
so practically speaking and biochemically it doesn't make sense to take a huge dose of vitamin C
because only a small fraction of that will be absorbed so we decided on the basis of meta-analyses
on basis of biochemical epidemiological studies that it's important to keep blood levels of
vitamin C very high that produce not really saturation but very high concentrations in circulating
cells in the blood and also cells in different tissues because vitamin C is very important and non-toxic
so we recommend now to get at least 400 milligrams a day so by saying at least 400 milligrams a day
we recognize that it's important to get much more than what the RDA is for instance
and we also recognize implicitly the safety of high dose vitamin C
so we don't specifically recommend many grams a day but we recognize also that high dose
vitamin C is very safe as a matter of fact the UL which is the upper tolerable upper level of intake
for vitamin C was established in 2000 at 2000 milligrams per day based solely on the transient
laxative effect of higher doses in some people which is really not a serious side effect
it's not really pathological or toxic
is the argument in favor of intravenous vitamin C in the possible therapeutic procedure that
does that still have a question? Well actually that's been greatly reinvigorated by some of these
pharmacokinetic studies after the Mayo Clinic studies as we discussed there was kind of a dismissal
of vitamin C the utility of vitamin C as a therapeutic agent in cancer and a lot of oncologists and
physicians became very uninterested in vitamin C this pedestrian molecule it's already been studied
by the Mayo Clinic it's failed so therefore it's time to move on however pharmacokinetic studies
that really demonstrated very clearly in these transport studies in molecular biology
something might throw
showed that when you give vitamin C intravenously you get much higher concentrations in the blood
than you do when you take it orally in depending upon the dose given intravenously you can end up
with millimolar concentrations in the blood when you take vitamin C orally it's tough to get
above about 200 micromole per liter in the blood concentration so millimolar you're talking about
70 or 100 times greater concentration of vitamin C when given intravenously and that led people
conducting these pharmacokinetic studies to think more carefully about why Cameron's work with
Pauline was so successful in Scotland and why the Mayo Clinic's work in Minnesota failed
and it's pretty clear that these these high levels of vitamin C exhibit cytotoxicity selective
cytotoxicity against tumor cells and this has been shown in cell culture experiments for many many
many years and even in the early 1980s Pauline himself published with Japanese colleagues
a paper showing that vitamin C had cytotoxicity against tumor cells in culture
and that this was completely nullified by the addition of catalysts to the culture medium
and catalysts of course quenches hydrogen peroxide so they surmise that the cytotoxicity was due
to vitamin C acting as a prooxenant and generating hydrogen peroxide which was then killing tumor cells
so this very mechanism was then rediscovered many years later and shown to occur when you get
these pharmacological concentrations of vitamin C in the blood when given intravenously
it starts generating hydrogen peroxide which attacks tumor cells and it seems to be very selective
either normal cells are protected by endogenous antioxidants or some other protective mechanism
as it play and that led to renewed interest in the prospect of using high dose IV vitamin C
as a junk of therapy and cancer and there have been many many anecdotal studies published case
histories published and a couple of phase one clinical trials published as well so I think there's
quite a lot of interest now but there are also quite a lot of issues that need to be much more
fully characterized for instance which types of human cancer are most sensitive to these high
concentrations of vitamin C which patients are the best candidates for high dose vitamin C at what
stage of cancer can vitamin C be given with chemotherapy drugs in a synergistic manner would
vitamin C negate the effect of some types of chemotherapy drugs should it be used in connection with
radiotherapy and what would be the optimum protocol for administration of vitamin C
for instance Cameron with his terminally old patient population these people were hospitalized
waiting to die so he could give continuous slow drip intravenous vitamin C high dose vitamin C
hour after hour day after day so retrospectively you're thinking about this and thinking that
hydrogen peroxide must have been rather continuously generated and rather continuously
attacking these tumor cells in vivo for many patients now who get high dose IV vitamin C it's given
in a periodic fashion two or three times a week very high doses so hydrogen peroxide is being
generated transiently and then after four to six hours the level of vitamin C in the blood is
right back at baseline no more hydrogen peroxide generation presumably so those kinds of issues whether
it's okay to have periodic generation of hydrogen peroxide through what kind of intermittent IV
vitamin C use or whether this continuous generation of hydrogen peroxide is more effective all these
issues are very nuanced and difficult and I think have to be really thoroughly characterized before
we'll really understand the merits of vitamin C against cancer but there are people that are
actively working in that area and they recognize all these issues. In 2001 the institute hosts its
first diet and not coming to the health conference and that also came with the first LPI advice for
the health research which is a $50,000 prize pretty remarkable time around for an organization that
is continuing on the treatment going out of business in 15 years before. Really amazing turnaround and
part of that has to do with I think Rick Hicks cultivation of donors over the years by always
putting information about bequest and playing gifts in the periodic newsletter that went out to
our constituents so people were aware from the mid-70s on and named the institute in their wills
and those bequest that came in very irregularly and unpredictably to the institute allowed us to
do really wonderful things including a doubt endowing new faculty positions within the institute
convening things like the diet and optimum health conference and giving that prize for health
research and also the fact that the cost of doing business here at Oregon State was much less
because we weren't having to pay rent any longer we weren't having to pay people to
participate in a large fundraising program or pay a controller bookkeeper and so forth so
a lot of the activities that had to be supported as an independent organization did not have to be
supported in this context of Oregon State University so costs were down and therefore the bequest
and the money that was coming in could be could be applied towards growth of the institute
instead of just merely sustaining the institute. Also in 2001 Jill Beckman arrived at the institute
talking a little bit about the background behind that and the fact that he is working ALS into
sort of open up a different angle of research for the institute. That's right there always been
interest of course in neurodegenerative diseases at the institute and
we were looking for a candidate who could open up that new area of research and
Jill Beckman was one who applied and he'd done some really outstanding work on molecular work on
ALS in Birmingham Alabama at the University of Alabama
showing that Paroxy nitrite is a very interesting destructive molecule that is generated
through the evolution of nitric oxide in the body very damaging molecule so his work really appealed
to us reactive nitrogen species was kind of a new avenue of research reactive oxygen species work
of course have been undertaken by many people all around the world for many years including some
at LPI but reactive nitrogen species was kind of a new a new facet of this that would be very
interesting pursue and he was given the Aether Helen Pauline in dad position because we thought it
would be would be nice to honor Linus Pauline's wife with another with the second in dad position
and at that time we had the money thanks to Bequest in order to do that and also some of the money
that came into the institute at that time was not just from Bequest but also from legal actions
as an example when the insurance companies refused to
reimburse us for legal expenses during the raffle litigation
I decided to sue the insurance companies because they weren't honoring our claims
and they made up reasons why you know they couldn't honor the claims but nevertheless are
commercial liability and directors and officers insurance I thought would apply
and I was shocked that they refused to honor these claims so we decided to sue them
and that was settled before going to trial and that resulted in quite a large amount of money
coming to the institute as well so we had money coming in from a number of different avenues that
allowed us to adopt these positions. Just a couple more questions we talked about the principal
investigators and balls and when it did any of the folks that have been made their figures in the last
10 years or so we're trying to have the institute. Well I think clearly the people who were
operating the research office were have been very important because balls probably reports
to the head of the research office and the money that are available through returned overhead
and through the research office have been very important to the institute over the years
the deans and departmental chairs have also been extraordinarily important because when candidates
are being interviewed and reviewed for a faculty position within the institute as a principal
investigator at the institute they have to have an academic home as well which means that the
chairperson of the appropriate academic unit and his or her colleagues and faculty members have
to vote on whether or not this candidate will fit into their department so it's a very
convoluted and entwined process of selecting someone for the institute and for
an academic department so all the departmental heads have been quite important as well.
That was your job change over time. Well my job has changed in so far as I obviously am no
longer the chief executive officer of the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine which was
kind of a parallel track for me and once that was finally legally dissolved and I didn't have to
think about that any longer and basically could focus on my responsibilities as administrative
officer for the institute and from the when we first moved here I took over editor ship of the
newsletter because we recognized that the newsletter continued to be an important educational
tool and fundraising tool for the institute and I thought I could do it and Don read thought I
could do it so I just started to do that unilaterally and that's been a lot of fun. We have historically
given out pilot project grants to fund initial research by people doing work related to the
institute of the mission in order to allow them to obtain enough data to apply for larger
more sustaining grants from say NCI or NIH and the work that they've done has always been reported
in the newsletter so talking to those people getting asking them for articles for the newsletter
editing those articles trying to translate that information from a very technical
language to language that's a little more friendly to the casual reader has been a lot of my
responsibility and then of course pursuing this option of a new building for the institute
it's been something that balls Ryan I've been working on right from the beginning very diligently
and then when the funding finally came together for that even before the funding came together
we spent quite a lot of time talking to architects and visiting buildings and so forth trying to
get a clearer idea of what it was we wanted and also to provide us with material that could be
shown to prospective donors so we wanted to have a good idea of what the institute could look like
what the new building could look like and have something that we could show to people a visual
representation of this model or something like that so he and I worked very closely on
on all that work and I became a member of the steering committee for the Linus Pong Science Center
so I'd say for the last couple of years two or three years I've been working very intensively
with user groups trying to identify issues that needed to be incorporated into the design and
given to the architects to design our building and also there's always been a bit of a fundraising
component to my position as well because I have such a long history with the institute and I know
about a lot of our past activities and I knew Linus Pong pretty well I'm often asked by our fundraiser
or other groups the Rudry Club, Blinds Club, different groups here at Oregon State University
and elsewhere to give talks on Pong and Orthomolecular Medicine or to provide
overviews of the research that's going on at the institute now and I rather often in two or
three times a year travel to scientific or medical conferences to make presentations on Pong and
Orthomolecular Medicine and to give those kinds of updates. My last set of questions is about the
building and opened this last September more or less and you obviously involved in that process
well it's just such a terrific change from the institute. One of her as I said was completely
satisfactory in the early days for the institute but as the institute grew we became very fragmented
because we had faculty in different buildings all over campus and it became less and less
likely to interact with fellow faculty who were part of the institute and of course I think that
decreases the collegiality and also diminishes the prospect for good meaningful scientific interactions
on a frequent basis that could generate new ideas and make progress in research projects.
So the new building has allowed almost all the institute principal investigators to be housed
together now. Joe Beckman is still in ALS but it's just a stone's throw from the Linus Pong
Science Center which is next to Nash which is the building that sits between ALS and the Linus Pong
Science Center so he's still physically very close to the institute although not part of the building
itself and being in a very spacious well lit modern building with open lab space and modular space
that's quite flexible is just such a such a wonderful inspiration for everyone and the interaction
with your colleagues now is dramatically increased as well because all the offices are aligned along
the north wall on the third floor and the fourth floor and there's an open atrium kind of a cathedral
less environment between the third and fourth floor a staircase in the middle there allows people
to get from one floor to the other so there's just this feeling of openness and integration that
is really wonderful. Well the next set of priorities I think are to expand and develop our
Micronutrient Information Center and also work on a new program in our outreach which is called
the Healthy Youth Program which is trying to introduce the concepts of good nutrition and lifestyle
among elementary school children and middle school children so that kids can get good ideas about
how to stay healthy when they're young in terms of exercise and eating well and also we still have
the ability to recruit more faculty for a healthy aging program. Once we recruit more faculty
for a healthy aging program I think we'll be saturated with respect to four principal investigators
per area having labs in the Linus Pong Institute. Well that's the end of my questions are there any
things that we didn't cover that come to mine off hand that we should talk about as far as
we can. Probably but I can't think of anything off hand so let me think about that.